around 250 million people have played
the wildly popular online game fortnight
in the year-and-a-half since its debut
it is described as a cross between
Minecraft and Hunger Games players
battle with guns and other weapons on a
fantasy island or work together in
creative mode they also build things as
well which is the Minecraft part 61% of
us teenagers have played fortnight
according to a 20-18 survey by Common
Sense Media it also found almost one in
four parents are worried about the
amount of time kids spend on the game
dr. sue Varma is a board-certified
psychiatrist and assistant professor at
the NYU Langone Medical Center welcome
thank you so it's not just for tonight
there are all of these kinds of games
that kids get intensely interested in
what is happening in their brains when
they get this kind of well addiction
there is such a flood of dopamine that's
resulting we're finding that just
anticipation alone of the video games
can increase your dopamine by 70% in the
brain which is the pleasure and reward
system but the problem is that these
young kids they're developing brain has
the foot on the gas but it doesn't have
a foot on the brake so we don't have the
same control and regulation the kids
don't know when to stop
so how is it yeah affecting their
development yes so we're finding that
kids often like there's a craving set up
where when you interrupt the kids they
get extremely irritable and we do know
that there have been some cases of
violence where kids are breaking into
their parents car to try to get their
devices they're stealing credit cards
now that's not the norm that's not the
baseline most kids are able to regulate
their playing but we are finding the
kids that are more vulnerable who might
be prone to depression or anxiety or
have difficulty making friends might be
using this as a form of coping or
avoidance so it's the executive function
ability that allows them to stop these
kinds of things but when does that kick
in when is it proper to sort of let them
figure out how to develop their own
executive functioning look it really
depends on the child right you have to
know the childhood do they have the
ability to be able to say no and really
what it comes down to is do they have a
more compelling activity right because a
lot of times kids are gonna say why do I
have to stop what's more interesting
than this I don't find homework
interesting but I think you have to give
them what we call a healthy diet of
other pleasurable activities nothing can
replace the
in connection if your kids really enjoy
spending time with you with friends
reward vadas behavior say can we go to
your favorite movie can we go to a play
can we go outdoor hiking can we go right
rock-climbing but isn't that part of the
problem here because I know certainly
from personal experience in our own
house and this isn't a problem actually
which is to say that the team play and
the group play and the connectivity to
friends absolutely intense and
pleasurable in a way that we would all
recognize from our own growing up
absolutely but we do need to give them a
proper opportunities and alternatives
and to give them choices and really the
brain the executive function is
developing up until the age of 25 you're
gonna have a lot of really mature
13-year old and really you have to take
it case-by-case basis do you have kids
in your house I do
did they play for tonight and they do
play for tonight and it's really
difficult because I was wondering how
hard it is on parents absolutely it's
very hard because look when you set
limits and those limits are broken
there's a breach of trust in the house
it says I thought that we were on the
same page but I'm finding that getting
the kids apart a hand in the
accountability and saying listen it's up
to you right you can choose this or you
can choose that but you can't have both
so we use something different in our
house we actually used and this was my
husband who figured this out because
he's really good at this stuff they've
done something called Circle which is on
your phone and it shuts off essentially
the game after 45 minutes so there's a
there's a list there's a set of
expectations it's taken a while yes I'm
sometimes it's been unplugged mysterious
yeah yeah but but it now they have know
that it's there's a device that sets the
time limit it's not a decision that
either I make that I have to be mean
about saying get off of it or that they
make that's the limit yeah and it's done
yeah and I think that helps all of a
solutely and you're giving the kids
natural consequences right and you don't
have to be the bad guy in this so saying
I didn't do it or setting a timer right
and letting them know that you do have a
20 minute warning before this stop so I
think giving them rules regulations
expectations boundaries reinforcements
oral and as a psychiatrist do you are
you seeing things in kids that concerns
you about these games I am like there is
a level of the competition right the
violence that sometimes I we're not
saying that this is what it's going to
lead to stuff outside but it is wiring
the brain to sort of set people up
against each other and a survival mode
mechanism that's what I keep hearing
though there's a lot of the thing raised
about the violence how worried should we
be about
and what should we do about that yeah so
if the kid look the problem is does a
child know the difference between
reality and fantasy aren't available to
draw the line to talk about yes and a
parent really should be on the lookout
for dangerous behaviors is your kid
starting to socially withdraw is there
other grades going down are they not
connecting to people it's a personal
hygiene going down are they preoccupied
with thoughts of death that's a big one
do they talk about suicide so many
parents are afraid to ask the difficult
questions because they think that
they're gonna plant seeds into the minds
of their children and let me tell you
this those thoughts if they exist have
been there for a year so no you know the
warning signs this does not happen
outside of context if we are talking
about dangerous behaviors in real life
there are things that already
pre-existed mental health issues and
this might be excessive what is a
difficult question to ask what is that
know do you feel like your life is not
worth living do you do you cry all the
time do you not get meaning or purpose
or pleasure do you not feel that people
like you some kids will tell you I feel
rotten to the core I'm feel unlovable
nobody loves me everybody hates me I
don't have friends in school I sit by
myself and have lunch I get bullied like
a lot of times parents want to turn turn
the other way because they don't want to
deal with issues they don't want to deal
with issues and themselves there might
be marital problems video games cause a
lot of conflict in couples because
there's a difference and parent and do
you think sometimes kids use these games
as a substitute for all the things that
they're lacking absolutely are worried
about yes and you know a lot of times
games do give kids who have problems
making friends it gives them an
opportunity because it gives them a
common ground for something to play with
so where do you think that in some
context kids that might have challenges
it might be a way but never use this as
a substitute for the real life
connections even social media it can
have a compulsive use you know we call
this sort of like a problematic
interactive social media use
Superman you're terrific really good
information
thank you we need to keep your number I
know I'm like have you